so idea of building a mobius bridge now
one problem is that if you make a band
you're supposed to walk on that band
across the bridge and that band slowly
turns well
at the end of the bridge you're falling
into the water that's no good
right however if you make your band kind
of a
cross section not like a crescent and
then you can move that cross session
you know through 180 degree and you
still have a place to stand on from one
end to the other so basically you can
kind of
look down this pathways and as you walk
across and you're nice and on the
horizontal surface you simply find that
that crescent rotates around you and
first you have your wall on the right
hand side and then you have it on your
left hand side but you can still walk
across
straight
and then you simply complete the loop
over the top and make sure that in doing
so the whole thing closes up on itself
so it forms an overall mobius band and
the hallmark of the mobius band is you
start on this side and you walk around
and you walk around on the inside you
walk around on the inside and you're
suddenly on the other side on that top
loop
and you could but you could still put
this over a river like a bridge this as
is you know would certainly function
like a bridge right
cool
well it's just one of several possible
designs
here is a mobius band you can see it has
this one twist and this is very simple
it basically uh you're walking on this
pretty much flat surface
and then the twist actually happens
on the return path and it essentially
turns vertical
and that allows you to essentially
support that particular bridge
or
if you don't want to use as a structural
support that supports from below
you could flip this thing over
and use it that way okay and now you're
walking on the silver surface here but
now of course you have a tunnel so your
structural support but that might be
aesthetically more interesting or more
pleasing so i think another totally
practical way of building a mobius
bridge
i'm surprised people aren't building
these they're brilliant well maybe do
you know of anyone building these yet um
there was one built uh not too long ago
in bristol and uh you have to look a
little bit but i'm in bristol yeah
better go check it out i will yes
so they're supposedly having i only have
seen pictures of it so but it looks like
it's an honest-to-god mobius bridge even
though it's kind of a flamboyant return
path that makes most of the twisting and
it's sort of a horizontal loop like that
i think
a more elegant and really structural
simple mobius bridge would be this one
here again we can look and you can see
very walk through or where you drive
through that is very simple
straight pathways so all the mobius
twist essentially happens
in that loop over the top you can see as
the flat band that forms the rod bit
goes up over the top it makes a 108
degree flip and comes back to the other
side
and that makes a perfect vertically
oriented arch that is strong enough so
it can act as a suspension
bridge
so i can actually hang the roadway you
know from the
vertical arch that is oriented in the
right way to give you maximal strength
what about mobius houses yes yeah
they're coming up
so
i claim both of these are mobius houses
now what's happening with all the color
let's look at this one first is it a
mobius band well we have to kind of
start up here we're running down there
we're running around the bottom we're
coming up the other side and yes indeed
we're on the other side so that tells us
this is indeed a mobius band
does it make a practical house
oh i think we oriented like that
there are houses that are slanted like
the towers in madrid for instance right
so there's nothing novel there probably
would have to either run the elevator at
an angle which you can certainly do as a
special track
so the question is okay all the green
stuff
maybe windows okay and you have a lot of
good office space and you know maybe
apartments and the like that have you
know perfect views but then down here to
be consistent the green stuff is on top
well what does that mean well that's
where you put your lobby that's where
you put your cafeteria that's what put
your library and they all want skylights
on the top of the flat part at the
bottom we essentially have a glass
ceiling and it nicely transitions
into the vertical part of the glass
which gives you the ordinary windows
that you might find in your office or in
your apartment here is another very
obvious mobius band
same idea we have very straight very
conventional you know um a building
block you know with maybe three four
stories uh worth of apartments or hotel
rooms or whatever and then a much larger
flat part along the bottom just as
before
that's where we might have you know the
lobbies and the restaurants and the
meeting rooms and the ballrooms and the
library and stuff like that so again
i think in both of these instances
these are mobius buildings that really
there's no doubt that they're mobius
bands and they're very practical and
from what i've seen by famous architects
kind of thinking about moby's houses
it's it's of much less obvious how they
might function and uh um for me it was
not always obvious to even see that
there indeed are mobius uh
configurations
we're gonna get one of these things
built you've got to get a grant and get
one made
yup
well somehow this doesn't want to come
up
okay if you look at that then it still
hangs together it seems to be like one
band actually it's a band that goes
around the loop twice and seems to be
somewhat intertwined